Olá como vão Então vamos mostrar como
está o
aplicativo essa é uma tela de login
Inicial que nós colocamos os
dados dos operadores que vão utilizar o
sistema a dashboard que vai poder
acompanhar as conversas então eu vou
entrar aqui com o
usuário hipotético que eu crii no no
banco de dados obviamente a gente pode
pode não vamos mudar esses usuários
né Deixa eu só localizar a senha aqui
então é um usuário chamado Pedrosa né
que foi criado que é um dos
operadores
então o Pedrosa entrou no sistema temos
as mensagens aqui ativas Então como é
que funciona o fluxo todas essas
conversas que estão vendo aqui à
esquerda São pessoas que foram criadas
como usuários E aí eu criei uma umas
automações que que tá do lado direito
aqui para criar um usuários falsos e tem
um usuário aqui que é verdadeiro que sou
eu Ok então a entrada de dados do
usuário verdadeiro é um pouco diferente
dos
usuários falsos mas aqui o uso da
api do Z Api para poder entrar os dados
é exatamente como seria no aplicativo de
produção Ok então esse aqui são usuários
que t eh perguntas aleatórias que eu
coloquei pro programa rodar então ele
recebeu essa mensagem Qual é a data de
validade aí o operador Tavares aqui eu
tô alugado como Pedrosa mas o Tavares
responde aqui ó do anos né e tem a data
e o horário que ele respondeu aí as
perguntas que ele vai respondendo tá
essa essa esse diálogo começou às 22
horas às 21 horas do dia 3 de Março
mesma situação
aqui simulando uma conversa com o
cliente e aqui importante ver que tem um
menu aqui em cima dos controles esses
contoles aqui são as tags você consegue
ver a tag aqui na lateral a dúvidas
Gerais eu posso mudar eu posso por
exemplo acrescentar o pós-venda e
atualiza aqui atualiza também no banco
de
dados ou se eu quiser tirar eu posso
tirar também deixar sem nenhuma tag tá
sem tag agora aqui e eu posso sei a
partir do momento que foi acusado uma
venda marcar a tag vendido aqui já está
marcado a tag vendido eu não vou clicar
aqui porque eu quero mostrar uma outra
funcionalidade Mas eu posso vou fazer
aqui só para vocês verem ó Pronto agora
ele passou a ser não vendido e aqui tem
uma mensagem embaixo se eu quiser
colocar vendido de novo tá aqui embaixo
também autorizou o banco de dados por
trás e eu posso mudar o visitador aqui
eu coloquei Larissa eu não conheci o
nome nome dos outros visitadores mas eu
pus aqui Márcio Marcos hipoteticamente
posso mudar aqui ó por exemplo mudar
esse aqui pro Márcio OK aí eu clico ou
aqui ou clico em qualquer lugar fora e
sai dos controles aqui tem as página de
história que eu já vou mostrar é a
página de métricas e a página de resumos
aqui ele mostra o resumo da conversa
atual o cliente da healthc pergunta
sobre o cadastro no site concentração de
um princípio ativo como celar um pedido
originalidade
dosagem e se ele já teve alguma conversa
anterior fechada a última conversa
anterior também aparece o resumo aqui tá
Então vamos fechar uma conversa aqui
para vocês verem como é que funciona eu
venho
aqui encerrar a conversa ele dá um aviso
aqui o resumo atual será movido para o
histórico uma nova interação de conversa
será iniciada Caso haja novo contato
Então se o cliente entrar de novo em
contato
a
conversa gera uma nova conversa as
mensagens na tela serão limpas Mas ficam
armazenadas no histórico quer continuar
sim aí a conversa sumiu
ok e por aí vai então eu vou gerar aqui
por exemplo um atendimento eu vou usar
aqui uma
outra
automação tem uma outra automação aqui
que é o é o Web Hook real tá porque que
meu telefone ele tá ligado diretamente
aqui então vou ligar só para vocês verem
eu mandando
mensagem era bom mostrar meu celular
também né mas eu tô com celular aberto
aqui eu vou mandar mensagem pelo
WhatsApp eu posso mostrar também isso na
reunião ao vivo então entro
aqui eu tenho duas linhas aqui no
telefone eu vou mandar paraa linha que
tá ligada no sistema tá
por exemplo vou mandar aqui uma boa
tarde tô digitando aqui no
celular
enviei entrou no sistema e vai atualizar
a tela agora aí pronto tá vendo
atualizou a tela aqui você deve ter
ouvido um barulhinho aí que quando chega
mensagem tem um aviso sonoro tá vendo
Boa tarde Se eu responder aqui aparece
no meu celular Colocar assim boa tarde
então foi lá mensagem enviada sucesso
via
WhatsApp e na minha tela tá aparecendo
Boa tarde deixa eu colocar aqui para
vocês
verem eu tô com o WhatsApp web aqui
ele então ó tá vendo eu mandei um boa
tarde para eles e recebi o Boa tarde
aqui então tá ligado no meu telefone ó
numa das minhas linhas
aqui e aqui é uma outra automação que
que manda um uma uma simulação de como é
que seria o pacote de dados vindo do
WhatsApp tá vindo do zapi Então vou
testar esse workflow para vocês verem
aqui ó Pronto ele vai mandar mensagem
chegou tá vendo a Bianca calvacante e
tem um código rodando aqui existe
uma um código rodando que gera vários
nomes baseados nessa lista aqui e gera
uma mensagem aleatória Então chegou a
mensagem da Bianca calvalcante eu
coloquei um dígito a mais aqui no número
dela para ela não para eu não mandar de
maneira inadvertida um uma mensagem de
WhatsApp para uma pessoa aí que pode at
ter o mesmo número mas eu respondo aqui
sim
possui registro vou responder
aqui e aí eu mando aqui não vai mandar o
WhatsApp porque esse número não existe
tá tem um dígito a mais aqui mas vai pro
banco de dados Ok então vamos lá no e no
histórico para vocês verem como é que
funciona ó histórico então todas as
conversas que foram encerradas estão
aqui aí eu clico aqui tem todas as
conversas anteriores Ok eu posso buscar
também ó por exemplo tem aqui um
registro Ana Ferreira João e tem dois
João Costa porque o sistema gerou
automático Tá mas são números diferentes
Então coloca aqui Maria Silva por
exemplo aparece a Maria Silva aqui
embaixo tá ou eu posso clicar aqui
também digamos diamos que eu quero o
resumo deixa eu limpar aqui o histórico
desse dessa conversa com a Ana Ferreira
aqui tá tem um botão que gera o resumo
dessa conversa tá
aqui pronto tá aí a o resumo da conversa
inteira
tá vamos voltar pra tela inicial e temos
a tela de métricas que eu implementei
taxa de conversão tempo médio de
atendimento e número de atendimentos eu
poderia ter colocado mais métricas aqui
mas eu quis parar por aqui porque às
vezes a gente pode avançar muito e vocês
não concordarem com alguma coisa então
taxa de conversão todo período tá aqui
como foram 17 conversas no total e foram
cinco conversas marcado como vendido a
taxa tá em torno de
30% e eu posso mudar esse ano esse mês
essa
semana hoje
Ok e personalizado escolher a data de
início data de fim aparece um calendário
aqui para eu escolher as datas tá vamos
colocar todo o período aí aparece aqui
as conversões por visitador Então aqui
tem a Larissa e tem o hipotético
visitador Márcio aqui mostrando que a
taxa de conversão do Márcio foi 80% da
Larissa foi 50% e do Marcos que é o
terceiro que eu cadastrei aqui 0% nesse
período Total ok
então tem por conversão por conversa e
tem conversão por visitador
tá tempo médio de atendimento 2 hor 26
minutos esse aqui é o tempo de cada
conversa por isso que é important deixa
eu voltar aqui encerrar as conversas
porque é um ciclo né quando o atendente
percebe que o cliente tá satisfeito ele
vem aqui e encerra a conversa tá para
poder as métricas fazerem sentido aqui
depois né tempo médio de atendimento
mesma coisa por mês ano personalizado
como eu já tinha mostrado número de
atendimentos também ele mostra nesta
semana neste mês neste ano todo o
período aqui depois a gente vai ter que
conversar um detalhezinho dessa métrica
aqui mas a gente conversa na reunião a
intenção que é só mostrar como é que tá
funcionando o aplicativo tá
ã Então é isso mostrei as
funcionalidades aqui e a gente pode
conversar de acrescentar mais algum tipo
de recurso
tá obrigado pela atenção de vocês aí